i have notes
not printed in front of me like usual
which means i'll have to press alt tab
and
check my notes occasionally but i
thought that in the spirit of this
in the spirit of what you're about which
is how about we
float freely in the waters let the
universe take us where it may
i thought how about let this
conversation take us or it may
please do or please allow it anthony
why don't you tell the audience a little
bit about
where you started from in your
intellectual journey so that's maybe
you're around teenager or late teens or
so
what your ideological i don't like to
use that word ideology but
for the sake of using a word that people
believe they understand
your ideological disposition at the time
and then how it changed and where you
are now
okay well i don't normally talk about
the teenage years but
i was pretty much a depressed
poetic kind of musician kid who skipped
school as much as possible
to smoke weed and drink beer and play
with my band and write angry lyrics
for the singer to sing and
my earliest experiences really were
of being a just dropping out of high
school and reading the encyclopedia
i didn't read it page for page but we
had this old colliers
encyclopedia encyclopedia yeah yeah and
i just went through that
from beginning to end you know again not
every single page but
it was just the most amazing experience
and i used to walk
uh to pretend that i was going to school
and listen to cbc radio
uh peter sofsky was alive at the time i
think it was morningside it was called
and you were in toronto or you were
where this is in british columbia
so i was in salmon arm which is some
nowhere place yeah if you see me go like
this
that's because for the people listening
or watching this there's a bit of a
delay
because anthony's in australia if i'm
correct yes right and i'm in toronto
and so if i need to get a all of this
gets edited out
eventually when i put up the pristine
version of this podcast but for now it's
going to be messy and
i forgot to ask you to record your audio
if you don't mind doing so
it's recording okay great great just
your own audio your instructions
yes yeah thank you man thank you and i'm
sorry to rudely interrupt if you don't
mind continuing
no not at all yeah so i wasn't in
toronto yet but i was in
salmon arm even silver creek which is
outside of salmon arm this very nowhere
place
and uh listening to peter zoski and he
would bring in the most amazing guests
that gave me far more of an education
than high school ever did
and what ended up happening is i went to
graduate with my friends
even though i wasn't graduating and one
of my friends mothers who
had inspired me so much when i was a
teenager going to her house and seeing
all the books
that she had she was a professor at york
actually
she said what the hell you're not
graduating
you should be a professor when you grow
up and somehow that
got in my head this image of being the
professor and
you know it's kind of sucked not going
to school and knowing that i was going
to have a life of
no education because at that time i
think it was true that if you didn't
have your
high school degree you know it would be
very difficult to get a job
and so um i took i i took the
embarrassing
step of going back to high school and uh
then i got myself into university and i
mean it's a long story the university
but
in terms of ideology i don't know that i
distinctly remember what it was but i
started
university in political science that was
going to be my focus
and i was working for the the school
newspaper
editing writing stories and so forth and
i met i think his name was glenn kemp
not glenn campbell that is
right glenn clark maybe and he had been
the premier of bc at the time
and um i interviewed him and i
thought within three minutes i never
want anything to do with political
science again or politicians
and so i went and changed my degree to
english literature and um
yeah but why what was it about what was
it about politics
just could tell he was lying to me and
you know i i don't know where i get that
but i just don't like
this kind of dual track modulating
of what's going on and yeah it just felt
so false to me
and i thought this guy's a tyrant and if
i
i remember that word coming up to and
i'd been reading you know plato's
republic and all this sort of stuff at
that time it was just the first time
encountering all those ideas
um and i just thought if i go that route
i'll be like this guy
and so i wanted to get as far away from
that as possible
so that was where that
puts me ideologically i don't know but i
had been reading lots of
you know existentialist literature and
philosophy and
was really into people like don delillo
in literature whatever that means in
terms of
of an ideology but it seems
quite uh embracing of a lot of different
chaotic elements going on in the world
and not getting too involved
in any of them so you can have the
widest possible perspective
and make decisions based on some sort of
rational basis wherever possible
were you a quick reader always
i'd say i'd say i'm relatively quick
but
slow enough to pay attention
okay so then what happened so you're in
your university years early i know that
it took you
quite some time to getting your phd and
that was because of quite a bit of
itinerancy and your
choices to what you precisely want but
why don't you continue through that rob
yeah well i started university in
british columbia at a small college
in uh salmon arm which is okanagan
university college which i think now is
subsumed by ubc
um and then i was in university of
northern british columbia which is way
up in prince george
somehow an uncle of mine had said why
don't you come work the summer
at para paints which is in brampton in
toronto
and i did that and i kind of liked it
there and i wound up
applying to university of toronto
university of toronto wanted
accepted me but only on a part-time
basis and i didn't want to go to
university part-time
i don't know why it had something to do
with like i had really bad high school
grades because that's interesting yeah i
dropped out and
i mean i i never cared about high school
at all i remember
one time i had an a on my report card
and i tore it up
i was embarrassed that i had a good
grade uh
which was in literature of course why
i think it was probably dramatic showing
off at the time i was
in front of my friends in the band and
we were sharing each other's report
cards and they all had bad grades and i
heard i had this a and they're like what
are you doing
or whatever but i i remember touring it
up as a sort of theatrical
thing to do so you had this
romanticization of what it means to be
this nihilist rock person
yeah i mean it was 1993
well i graduated uh i was supposed to
graduate 95 so i graduated in 96 but
somewhere in 93 94 this is when i got
this grade
it was like nine inch nails pretty hate
machine
hate everybody hate yourself hate
success
uh and all the bands i followed if they
weren't
bootstrapped fugazi kind of indie
do-it-yourself people
then they were somehow
anti-establishment or
at least they were preaching that you
know later you investigate this
and there's a lot more corporate
interest in it than you thought at the
time